hi Sandra this is Michael Furtick
founder and CEO of reputation calm you
asked what are we doing specifically to
spur innovation and job growth if you
look at the trillion dollars of wealth
that's been created on the internet so
far it's mostly about advertising ninety
percent of the wealth created on the
internet has been about advertising
which means that data are being
collected about each of us they're being
sold they're being shared without our
permission I believe that the next
trillion dollars of wealth on the
internet was going to be split 50-50
between services that expose your
private information like advertising but
also services that protect your private
information that's our mission our
mission is to create a whole new
category of wealth creation a whole new
category of job creation and innovation
around protecting consumer information
and giving you giving users control back
over their personal data so that's how
we're doing it